so I think a good starting point is to
think about you know what software would
be like if software projects really
worked properly I think that we could
expect as many software projects
succeeding as failing we could we could
imagine there's many projects being
um over under budget
um early and delighting their users as
over budget behind schedule and annoying
their users but I don't think that's
what we think of as normal I think that
mostly what we think of is something
like this and I think that's saying
something fairly profound about the way
in which we think about and practice
software development
um I like this little
um GIF animation of the orbits of the
planets in the solar system based on two
different models of the solar system
this really is a way of representing the
concept visually of paradigm shift and
this was a paradigm shift so for tens of
thousands of years Humanity held the
view that you that the Earth was still
and and everything in the sky just was
just orbited around the earth or went
round the Earth in some Manner and that
all made sense if you looked at the sun
and the moon and the stars they all
proceeded around the earth very nicely
and then there were these pesky things
called planets the word planet in
ancient Greek is means Wanderer and
that's because these things didn't seem
to obey any sensible rules they just
seem to wonder about in the sky
um so people try to predict where the
planets would be and they came up with
models like the one that you see on the
screen here which is complicated and
you've got these funny curly bits in the
in the red orbits of the planets
what that model is is you know is
complicated and nasty to to work in
um what happened here in this example is
that sometime later we had people like
Copernicus and Galileo and Kepler come
along and challenge that view and have a
completely different perspective they
changed the perspective so that instead
of seeing the Earth at the center of the
universe they saw the Sun at the center
of the universe
that's still wrong but it's a much much
better approximation when you start
talking about orbits in solar systems so
what's going on now is much easier to
model much easier to understand much
easier to predict but one of the
implications of this is that the rules
for the new paradigm don't fit the old
Paradigm and vice versa I think this is
a very good analogy of what I'm talking
about when we start thinking about and
talking about software development
um I think that we've got the model
wrong for software development and we
need a paradigm shift and really that's
what I want to talk to you a little bit
about today
so what does software engineering really
mean
um naresh and I were talking just before
I started here about about some of this
and
um I I think to some degree the term
software engineering has become devalued
in our profession we think about it as
either meaning something nasty and
bureaucratic and heavyweight which which
doesn't allow us to do very good job
or just means coding and I think neither
of those things are true I I think
that's those are poor descriptions in
either way and I think one of the
reasons for certainly the first of those
interpretations is that we got we've got
the model quite quite significantly
wrong in terms of what it is that we're
talking about I think this is a fairly
common view of what
software development software
architecture software design is for it's
about trying to trying to fix the things
that we can't afford to get wrong
um what's engineering for it's it's that
and I think that's
partially true for physical devices like
airplanes or cars or even Donuts but
it's not really true even then and it's
certainly profoundly not our problem
this is not anything to do with the
problem of software development for one
really important reason I think what
that is based on what that idea is based
on is really the idea of production
lines and the ability to automate and
regularize repetitive processes that's
not our gig that's not our problem
uh one of the things that is really
unique about software and and these days
all digital assets but but profoundly
true for software is that you know our
software our stuff is you know we we we
come up with with the design for some
code and that code is then generates a
sequence of bytes that represents the
systems that we're building
at that point once we have that sequence
of bytes we can cut clone that sequence
of bytes essentially for free
that's a freedom that wasn't possible
didn't exist before the concept of
digital assets occurred really and now
you know what does what does what does
production mean for our software
um for a physical device the production
of many physical devices is a complex
thing for us it's essentially free we
press the button we can clone the bytes
that represent our system for free
that's a very different thing it means
that the the act of software creation is
very very significantly different from
the act of other forms of creation it
means that our problem is almost
entirely an exercise in design
and not an exercise in production
the other thing to think about is when
we start thinking in terms of
engineering is that all engineering is
not the same engineering If You're
Building Bridges is different than if
you're building spaceships or or
electrical devices or chemical plants or
whatever else each of these things has
their own different uniquenesses so one
of the other things that we can be
fairly certain of is if we come up with
a discipline for software engineering it
will be ours it will be unique to
software and focused on
the important parts of software
um so one of the ways but even when we
take that into account
I think that we often have a fairly
naive view of engineering anyway one of
the examples that I think is fantastic
that we've got access to at the moment
is that these are SpaceX effort to build
spaceships that go to Mars if you're in
at all interested in this kind of thing
you can watch World Class Cutting Edge
engineering developing things that have
never been created before
Live on YouTube
um and that's a really interesting
experience because it's not what we
think it is it's not some bureaucratic
approach of just assembling all of these
things every single one of these things
every change to one of these things is
an experiment
um this you know starts with you know
you've got some kind of design and
you're going to build some some kind of
craft like this but to do that you're
going to try stuff out you're going to
evaluate you know different parts of the
system this is a very early prototype of
the the Raptor engine that drives this
spacecraft and you're going to get stuff
wrong things going to blow up and
stuff's going to go wrong but you're
going to learn from that that's one of
the properties of engineering one of the
the Hallmarks of engineering disciplines
in other fields is that we try stuff out
we break things and we learn from the
breakages and we find out how not to
break in the same way again in future
and then we'll try small pieces of
prototypes that we can try out ideas and
experiment with and stuff will still go
wrong stuff will still blow up
um occasionally and then sometimes we
start to get some successes we can
actually start to to in this case fly
some of these devices
and we end up with with with functioning
spacecraft that's how real engineering
works that's how design engineering
works even when it's something as big
and complicated as a space a space
rocket
so I would argue that engineering the
kind of engineering that's closer to
what we need we need to do the the kind
of engineering that we're in that is
interesting from our point of view is
always about exploration and discovery
so engineering is about exploration and
discovery
software development is about
exploration and Discovery too
one of the things that matters if we are
in that kind of Realm and I think
profoundly we are is that what the
implications of that is that if we are
in the realm of always exploration and
Discovery to some degree then we need to
adopt the tools to become experts at
Learning the first of those is iteration
we want to be able to make change in
many small steps so that we have more
opportunities to observe the progress
that we make in each one of those steps
we want to be able to gather feedback we
want to collect information from our
changes our experiments our evaluations
and understand what's going on
we want to make progress incrementally
we want to we want to change our
software development approach from
trying to mimic some kind of illusory
production line to be no more
evolutionary approach we want to
incrementally grow the systems that we
work on I would argue very
um I think I think it's a profound
aspect of human creativity not just
about software development if you look
at the development of any complex system
it's a process of incremental
evolutionary progress think for a minute
about the first iPhone
the first iPhone was a remarkably crude
device compared to a modern iPhone
and I'm certain that when they built it
the first version they had ideas about
changes that they would make in the next
version and and so on but they had no
idea where it would end up
10 or 15 years later they did they
didn't have that kind of picture
um so the iPhone has been incrementally
evolved developed over time you could
say the same thing about cars or
airplanes the first cars were incredibly
crude and dangerous devices but over
time they've come to the point where
we're on the verge of having fully
automated self-driving electric vehicles
that will you know are remarkably safe
in comparison to those early days that's
what real engineering looks like we
learned the lessons of the past
sometimes nasty lessons sometimes
lessons that involve hurting people but
we learn those lessons we we refine our
engineering approaches to try and
eliminate the failures of the past and
we just continue to grow incrementally
in software we can make that incremental
uh evolutionary approach to design much
faster much more incremental much
smaller steps and we should that gives
us a better chance of gathering feedback
in and carrying out our expression our
experience efficiently
which brings us on to the next of these
challenges if we want to become experts
at learning we need to start working in
more experimental ways if we think of
every change to our system as a form of
experiment that positions us well to be
able to take advantage of the learning
that we're carrying out
one of the fascinating ideas of these
kind of combinations of of ideas if you
think if you think about working
iteratively using feedback making
incremental developments and working
experimentally is it gives us an
opportunity of hitting the target
whatever the target is and whenever it
moves think for a moment of you know
having some kind of goal in mind
and we we're going to start
experimenting randomly we don't care
what what the experiment is we're going
to try something and figure out whether
it moves us closer or further from our
destination so as well as the ability to
make a change in small steps we've got
some kind of measurement that determines
whether we're getting closer to our
Target owner
if we work this way in small steps we
carry out the experiment we then measure
to see whether it got us closer to our
destination whatever our destination was
or whether it took us further away we
eliminate the steps that take us further
away we keep the steps that get us
closer and over time we will we will
incrementally iteratively
um get closer and closer and closer
towards the Target and that's true even
if the target moves so this is a
profoundly powerful way of hitting any
Target that we choose to set this is how
all real learning takes place this is
how science works this is how
engineering Works in other disciplines
this is how engineering ought to work in
our discipline too and the last of my
five things for optimizing for learning
the thing that I think that
distinguishes
um knowledge Creation in engineering
from knowledge Creation in science is
the idea of being empirical so we are we
are profoundly practical as engineers
and it's really about what really works
so how we determine those targets how we
decide what the success means for for
our experiments and our incremental
Discovery is important in monitoring
what really happens in production is uh
is is a really valuable trait
software develop development is also
about managing complexity
we build systems that exceed the
capacity for us to hold all of the
detail in our heads and so therefore we
need to work in ways that allows allow
us to cope with that complexity that we
can't otherwise deal with
and in this category there are another
five things that can help us to do that
we want to work in smaller pieces we
want to divide the problem up into small
pieces so that we can do work in one
place without that work impacting on
another so we need to take the
modularity of the systems that we create
seriously
and to do that we need to draw lines of
abstraction in our design so that one
module can interact with another module
without knowing the detail of how that
other module works this is deeply
important and and certainly there are
some people and I wouldn't argue with
them very strongly that would define you
know what it is that we do for a living
in in developing software as being or
nearly all about abstraction
um we need to separate the concerns we
need to divide up the problems the
systems that we create into pieces that
are focused on part of the problem
ideally well I would argue that we
should be able to separate the concerns
completely so each part of the system is
focused only on one part of the problem
and that makes for software that's
that's easier to deal with imagine that
the complexity is managed we're going to
manage the coupling of these components
carefully as well with generally a
trending preference towards looser
coupling rather than tighter coupling
but actually it's more about appropriate
coupling at the right levels as we're
working through these things and finally
we need to think about cohesion as well
making sure that the parts of the system
that are closely related are close
together so we can deal within those in
one in one place and the parts that are
unrelated are separate that's the other
extent end of the spectrum the
modularity part so that we can change
those in
independently of one another
all of these things are necessary for us
to manage the complexity
I would argue that
um that this gives us a practical
definition for what makes code good a
practical
set of tools with which we can evaluate
the quality of our code and the systems
that we build if you think for a moment
of
um two versions of of a system it
doesn't matter what the technology is it
doesn't matter what the problem it's
solving but if you had two versions of
the same system one of them was modular
Loosely coupled good cohesion good
separation of concerns and good lines of
abstraction and the other didn't
then which one would you prefer to work
on I think fairly obviously it's the
first one
the first one would be easier to change
easier to test easy to reason about
easier to modify easier to understand
where something went wrong and to fix
all of those things the second one is
almost by definition a big ball of mud
that is going to be terrifying to work
on
so I would argue that a good practical
definition for good code is that it
exhibits these properties
once we decided that the code works I
would say that you know the rest of
these things are really what define the
quality of our code yes it needs to be
fast sometimes yes it needs to be
secured sometimes but those are kind of
second order effects and we can add
those effects later if we've got these
properties in our code
so some principles for applying this
kind of engineering thinking we want to
optimize for learning so that we can
kind of explore and and grow our
understanding of the systems that we
create and our solutions to the problems
that we're aiming to solve with them we
want to optimize to manage or limit the
complexity of the systems that we build
so that we can work on them sustainably
continuously on an ongoing basis and be
able to change them and morph them and
shape them to meet the needs as the
needs may change and as our
understanding deepens
um some of the tools that help us to
achieve these things are to start
thinking of controlling the variables to
make sure that you know when we're
looking at our part you know our pieces
in isolation they are genuinely in their
isolation so that we can understand the
impact of ideas and so on we want to be
able to make decisions based more on on
evidence rather than just guesswork and
so we want to run the experiments to to
try out our ideas and to evaluate them
um we want to
one of the other lessons that we can
certainly learn from science is to
always start with the assumption that
we've not got the correct answer yet
and that sounds like a kind of weird
thing to say in many ways but it's
profoundly the better place to start if
we start out assuming that our ideas are
perfect and we just push on ahead and
they're not perfect that's going to come
as a surprise and we probably haven't
worked in a way that allows us to take a
step back and correct them if we start
out assume that our ants our answers or
or design choices or understanding is
incorrect then we're going to be looking
for ways in which it's incorrect and
we're going to take a slightly more
defensive approach to design and
implementation so that when we find out
how they're incorrect we can fix that
easily
this is deep this is deeply part of the
philosophy of science these days
scientists these days nearly always talk
about ideas of falsifiability so that's
another idea that we can bring to
software think for a moment of something
like automated testing what does it mean
if all of your automated test pass it
might mean that your software is doing
okay it might mean that all your tests
are rubbish or it might mean that your
tests are really good but you've missed
the crucial thing that shows that
something's wrong what does it mean if
one test fails it means your software is
not good enough so we can never ever
prove that our software is good
but we can disprove it we can prove that
it's not good enough when we have a
single failing test so falsifying things
is the stronger statement on the reality
of our systems and we can use that kind
of thinking too and all of these ideas I
think are closer to engineering thinking
than we would normally think of you know
if we were thinking in terms of software
as a craft rather than an engineering
discipline
one of the tools that I think profoundly
amplifies our chances of
doing these things successfully is to
optimize for good testability
we're going to write code that's easily
testable or prefer code that's easily
testable and I'd like to explore that in
in a bit more detail to kind of see what
what that means
so let's think for a moment what it is
I've already stated my assumption that
quality is based on modularity cohesion
separation of concerns and all of those
good things so what drives our ability
to put that kind of quality into code in
the absence of test driven development
well it's kind of down to the skill
experience and integrity of a programmer
it's
there's nothing else that kind of forces
us to do a good job of this
test driven development is something
unusual and it starts off by it's best
described by red green refactor and what
we're going to do in test driven
development is that we're always going
to write a test first and we're going to
run the test and see it fail
now we're going to once we've got a
failing test and it's failing in the
right way we're going to write some code
to make the test pass and see it pass
and then we're going to refactor the
code and the test to make them clean
elegant more General whatever we want of
them while we're in the stable states of
having a passing test that's all great
stuff really good but think for a moment
about what that means in terms of our
approach to design the first thing that
we're going to do is that we're going to
write a test before we've got any code
that maps that test pass so what that
means is that puts us in the position of
a consumer of our own code so we're
going to design our code from the
outside in rather than the inside out
our job is to try and write this test to
evaluate the behavior of of this piece
of code now we'd have to be a strange
kind of crazy person to want to make our
own lives more difficult so what we're
going to do at this point is try and do
this in a way that makes our own life
easier we're going to write we're going
to prefer code that's easy to test so
test driven development automatically
applies a pressure on us to generate
more testable code
so what is it that makes code more
testable
well obviously it has to work once we
run the test it should pass and that
tells us that it works but it also needs
to be more modular we want to be able to
test our code in pieces and evaluate
those pieces of code in isolation of
other pieces
we'd like them to be Loosely coupled so
it's easy for us to tear out these
pieces of code and we're not going to
have a horribly difficult time to get
them into the state that we want them to
be to be able to run our tests
we'd like them to be highly cohesive so
that when we've tested them we know that
that behavior in the system actually
works and that there's not some other
sneaky parts of the system somewhere
else that's doing something similar and
fooliness
and we want a good separation of
concerns so that we can focus on just
one part of the problem focus our
testing on evaluating just that and not
bringing in a whole bunch of other
problems like persistence or UI
considerations or whatever else it might
be and lastly we want to have lines of
abstraction we want to have information
hiding in the design of our system so
that we can deal with one part of this
this system in isolation of other parts
and maybe fake those other parts or
whatever else it is that we want to do
so all of these properties that earlier
I argued make a good definition for what
we count as high quality in code are
Amplified by a by our ability to operate
um through tester and development
what this means I said earlier I I
thought that test run development was
unusual so what this means is that in
addition to the skill experience and and
integrity of an individual programmer
we use the skills of test driven
development to amplify those things that
we value and we end up with a sum that
is greater than the parts we end up with
amplifying our ability to produce these
nice high quality design modular Loosely
proper World highly cohesive systems
with good separation of concerns and
good abstraction
this is a kind of talent amplifier it's
not going to make a bad programmer great
but it will make a bad programmer better
and it will make a great program a
greater and I think that's very unusual
I can't think of anything else that does
this in quite the same way in software
development so I think this is a
remarkably powerful tool to amplify our
talent whatever that might be as
software Developers
I want to give you just a a bit more
concrete example to just show what I'm
talking about this is very simple
example in code so we've got here a car
and this car has got a petrol engine and
as part of this code we've got a
function that course start and that puts
the car into the gears into neutral
applies the brakes and then starts the
engine on the car
okay so let's write a test for this
piece of code
here's my test should start car engine
we're going to create a new car we're
going to say start the car and now
there's nothing to assert I I can't I
can't actually
um I can't actually do anything here
that I could choose to break
encapsulation and dig into the workings
of this class that's a terrible idea I'm
just going to end up with my tests
overly coupled to the solution so we're
in a bit of a mess now so what can we do
instead
so let's start looking from the other
way around so let's let's do the test
driven development thing so should start
a better car engine
so we're going to start off what we
really want to achieve is we'd like to
be able to see that the engine started
successfully
so why don't we write some code that
says that let's just assert that the
engine started successfully
and that's going to happen when we start
the car as before
so what that means is that we need to
pass the engine to the better car so
that we can hold on to a copy of the
engine
and we're going to create a fake engine
that allows us to do this is in reality
we might use a mocking library or
something like that for this but here's
my implementation of a fake engine just
so you can see how that works all this
does is it just records the fact that
start was called and then allows us to
query where the start was called
so here's my better car now and that's
my implementation uh it's very similar
to the previous one but it's different
in this one key aspect
we're now passing in the engine we do
independency injection
um in order to make our code more
testable but let's just think about the
implications of that
so the first thing is is that when we
start thinking about this in production
we can still create a car with a petrol
engine which behaves in precisely the
same way as uh the the the the the car
did originally it's going to do all the
same things except now it's testable but
the implications of that is that we've
improved the modularity of the code
we've now we've now teased apart
um better car and the engine in this
case the petrol engine
and so each of these bits of code is a
bit more focused on what it is that it's
doing and more isolated than before
in one very practical sense the better
car doesn't know how to create an engine
whereas previously the car had to know
how to create an engine
so that's reduced the coupling between
those two and it's improved the
modularity
it's also improved the cohesion so now
all the stuff that's about petrol engine
Nets is inside the petrol engine and all
the stuff stuff that's about carnets is
in the better car and they are separate
the car depends Less on engines than it
used to in fact it only deals with an
abstraction of an engine with the engine
interface in this example
and
lastly the the um that that line of
abstraction is clearly defined we we now
know what that is so so this by making
this trivially simple change to make my
car more testable it is more modular
it's more cohesive it's got better
separation of concerns it's got looser
coupling because we the car no longer
knows how how to create an engine and
um and best of lines of abstraction
because those abstractions are more
clearly defined in the interactions
between the car and the engine
these are good things the result of that
is that we can create a car in
production with the petrol engine we can
create a car with an electric engine so
the car the code's more flexible we can
use it in many more circumstances and if
we're some kind of crazy person we can
even create a car with a jet engine
this is just better code
uh and I don't think anybody would argue
with that and it's better I didn't do
anything else I didn't I didn't think
hard about the design all I did was
worked to make it a bit more testable
and as a side effect of just that
we've improved the quality of this piece
of code
as I say I I think that's fairly
remarkable and I don't think that
happens very often in software
development
I talked earlier about the need to work
experimentally and that's deeply
important we've already talked about
some of the things that add up to
allowing us to do that but we need to be
able to take pieces of our system and
experiment on those individually and
some of the experiments will certainly
go wrong and some of them we'll need to
be able to take smaller pieces any and
and and and evaluate those as kind of
just experiments that we're going to
throw away and not using real production
and again some of these things will go
wrong
but that's the nature of experiments if
your experiments don't sometimes go go
wrong you're not really experimenting
one of the superpowers of Science and
Engineering is in reality we learn more
when our experiments go wrong and so at
some level we want our experiments to go
wrong some of the explosions that I
showed in the pictures from SpaceX were
actually test pieces that they meant to
blow up on purpose to see what would
happen
we want to make progress in small steps
so we want to optimize to allow
ourselves to get work iteratively in a
very fine-grained degree so that we can
capture more feedback we can
um use these small steps also to do the
next important thing which is to control
the variable gather feedback and control
the variables if we're working in small
steps predicting the results and
controlling the variables what this
means is that we can really understand
what's going on the small steps limit
the scope of our changes if you make a
change to your production system and you
find that it increases user sign up by
30 percent
is that a success or a failure
the real answer is that you don't know
if You released your change alongside
500 other changes some of which also
might have improved the value of the
sign up you haven't yet no idea
um if you focus down and you you release
only that change and your your sign up
went up by 30 then maybe you've got a
result
maybe not it may be maybe maybe the
variance is different so you need to
look at this more scientifically and
think about what the variables are think
about what the impact on your decision
making is but all of this allows us to
focus in and have a better chance at
solving the problems before us
I I've been using this feedback picture
to represent the ideas of continuous
delivery for a very long time now
um at the outside is the kind of core
idea of continuous delivery we want to
be able to have an idea get that idea
into the hands and users and collect
information to discover whether it's a
good idea or a bad idea at the inside
we've got the very fast cycle that I've
just been describing of test stream
developments and in between we've got
the use of executable specifications
acceptance testing to evaluate when
there are systems Deployable configured
correctly does the things that users
want is releasable and so on
um this is all part this is deeply built
into the practice of continuous delivery
and this idea gives us this ideal
platform for carrying out a certain
class of certain classes and experiments
this is a one of my favorite quotes from
uh most people's favorite physicists if
you're nerdy enough to have a favorite
physicist it doesn't matter how
intelligent you are if you guess and
that guest can't be back by experimental
evidence then it's still just a guess so
if we're looking to become more like
Engineers we need to start moving
outside the realm of guesswork and into
the realm of experimentation Gathering
feedback collect managing the variables
and so on
another of these tools that's remarkably
useful and Powerful is the idea of speed
uh we if we optimize to shorten the
cycle of our feedback and improve the
quality of our feedback what that does
over time it starts to drive out the
costs that are inherent to our
development approach and that allows us
then to start fixing some of those
problems that we highlight by trying to
up the speed of feedback and iteration
it drives out the problem and and makes
it more clear that starts to get us
focusing on trying to make the things
that we the way in which we're working
the engineering processes that support
us more repeatable more reliable more
more focused higher higher performance
more efficient over time and that gets
us into all sorts of interesting
territory of again controlling the
variables through Version Control uh
alternating nearly everything and so on
this is a picture of a deployment
pipeline that I use to describe the
mechanism that's at the heart of the
ideas of continuous delivery and the
idea of a deployment pipeline is that we
build essentially a machine that goes
from commit to releaseable outcome we
automate all of the creation the the
production and validation steps on our
routes to production and this becomes
our only route to production so if we
commit a change here we're going to get
fast feedback on whether as change is
releasable
when I advise my clients I usually
describe them to look at this first part
which is largely focused on the design
part of the challenge the development
team facing part of the challenge and
get feedback from here in under five
minutes
and then the second part of the pipeline
is all focused on the releasability of
our changes is it does it do what our
users want is it configured correctly is
it secure enough is it fast enough is it
regulatory compliant and so on and we
automate all of that too and get an
answer back here I'd usually shoot for
under an hour and that leaves us then
we've just been able to push the change
out into production
foreign
not very long ago
that Alan K was also attending and he
described engineering as design simulate
and build and this model that I've just
presented
solutely fits that picture
so if we start off with a deployment
pipeline we feed our changes into here
this first part of the pipeline is all
about the design problem it's about
giving fast clear feedback on the nature
of our changes we get fast feedback on
the quality of our designs through test
driven development as I've already
described then the second part of the
pipeline is about simulating the
behavior of our system in
production-like environments in all
sorts of ways that are interesting
enough to us to allow us to determine
whether that change is releasable enough
and that leaves us with what K calls
build but we just call pushing this out
into production that may be still a
complicated part of the problem but from
our point of view in terms of our
continuous delivery it's always simpler
because we're just pushing something out
that we know to be good because we've
already simulated is in production and
designed it well using these mechanisms
if it doesn't allow us if whatever it is
that we choose to do in terms of trying
to establish an engineering discipline
if it doesn't allow us to build better
software faster it doesn't count as
engineering
and that's really my primary argument
engineering is the stuff that works and
so I think that's a reasonable statement
to be able to focus